plus jamais mais plus jamais de problème
de batterie jean jamais juste après
l'intro salut les gens avaient à l'écran
c'est françois pour la chaîne explique
mans encore je suis ravi de vous
retrouver après cette petite pause
estivale
et justement aujourd'hui on va inaugurer
un nouveau format pour la chaîne que je
vais essayer de faire assez
régulièrement ça va être des formats un
petit peu plus court qui vont aller
directement à l'essentiel pour vous
donner des petites astuces des petits
type de film maker là pour vous
simplifier la vie dans vos tournages et
et puis faire de meilleures vidéos ou du
moins de les faire plus confortablement
d'ailleurs si vous vous intéressez à la
vidéo à la création de vidéos tout ça
vous pouvez bien entendu
cliquez sur le petit bouton s'abonner ça
va pas changer ça après les vacances
puis vous serez notifié à chaque fois tu
auras une nouvelle vidéo chaque fois
qu'il aura une nouvelle astuce un
nouveau truc pour vous aider dans vos
vidéos aujourd'hui on va donc parler
d'un problème qui peut se résoudre assez
facilement mais qui généralement peut
être source de stress de petites galères
c'est les batteries alors si comme moi
avant vous trimballez watts mille
batterie pour être sûr de pouvoir tenir
toute une journée en shoot que moment
donné vous étiez en train de filmer il y
avait presque plus de batterie donc
c'est le stress parce que est ce qu'on
va pouvoir filmer jusqu'à la fin où est
ce qu'on va avoir un moment de coupure
pour pouvoir changer la batterie et
cetera ou mettre un grip tout ça bref il
ya une solution vachement plus simple
que j'ai découvert bas cet été
ou que du moins j'ai expérimenté cet été
et vous allez voir c'est hyper pratique
ça coûte vraiment pas cher c'est tout
con le truc c'est qu'on peut recharger
beaucoup de boîtiers par leurs ports usb
alors pas tous il faut vérifier la
compatibilité mais sur une majorité de
boîtiers le port usb il sert aussi à
l'achat
ce que je me suis dit c'est que j'allais
y brancher tout simplement une pouvoir
banque un truc on ne peut plus standard
un truc hyper basique et pas cher et
j'avais bricolé au départ une espèce de
petites accroches une tâche qui tenait
un petit peu comme elle pouvait c'était
pas fou mais ça fonctionnait alors je
n'osais pas me lancer sur un tournage
run and gun genre mariage avec mama
bricole et puis je suis tombé par hasard
sur une pub de small rig
j'aime beaucoup les produits small rig
mais cette vidéo n'est absolument pas
sponsorisé est donc cet accessoire c'est
une petite pince qui va venir se fixer
sur la cage ou sur la poignée comme j'ai
pu le mettre moi sur lequel on va
pouvoir accrocher une power manque et je
vous mets un lien dans la description ce
qui fait que quand je pars sur un
tournage je vais poser sur cette attache
ma batterie je vais la brancher en usb
et magie ça va recharger en même temps
que la caméra est en train de
fonctionner la batterie interne ce qu'il
faut quand même garder la batterie
interne donc s'est attaché le coût de 20
balles et la batterie ça coûte à peu
près pareil donc ça coûte vraiment rien
du tout ce qui fait que sur les plus
grosse journée de shooting à savoir les
mariages que je fais qui vont de 9
heures du matin généralement à une heure
du matin le lendemain ben en gros avec
une power banques et la batterie interne
bah j'en ai assez je n'ai pas à me
soucier de si je vais avoir assez de
batteries s'il va falloir que je les
change etc ça marche tout seul et ce qui
est vachement bien c'est que comme la
power banque va charger la batterie à
l'intérieur au moment où la power
banques et les nazes va vous avez encore
toute la batterie interne du boîtier qui
fonctionne donc on a largement le temps
de voir venir
moi généralement par sécurité je pars
avec deux power banque vraiment vraiment
ko parce que j'utilise jamais les deux
power banques mais si jamais j'avais
besoin
eh ben je peux tout à fait changer la
power banque laisser tourner ma caméra
la rebrancher et ça me fait un petit
changement de batterie à chaud sans
aucune coupure sans rien et sans aucun
stress alors il existe aussi des
accessoires qui permettent de mettre de
très grosses batteries les vélos clé
batterie de caméras d'éclairage tout ça
mail avantages de cette solution là
c'est que ça n'alourdit pas non plus de
manière excessive le ring un ca à ça
ajoute quelques centaines de grammes
grand maximum ça ne nous donne pas un
truc qui pèse 1,1 demande donc à tous
qui coule dans cette solution ça reste
léger c'est hyper fiable ça nous donne
une autonomie extraordinaire a largement
suffisante pour n'importe quel shoot et
puis voilà ce n'est pas besoin d'en dire
plus c'est ce nouveau format ses courses
et direct c'est concis et si ça vous a
plu vous pouvez mettre le traditionnel
coup deux blaster sur le pouce en l'air
qui se situe juste en dessous de ces
vidéos vous abonner si c'est pas déjà
fait et puis moi je vous dis rester
curieux et à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo